[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire football à
quelques jours du début du mondial
l'équipe de france féminine s'est
entraîné ce matin à clairefontaine
devant plusieurs centaines de jeunes
venus de croissy sur seine
tous les détails dans ce magazine basket
l'entente le chesnay versailles s'est
imposé ce week-end en finale de playoffs
de prénationale un résultat qui permet à
l'équipe de monter dans le championnat
de nationale 3 nous recevrons des
membres de l'équipe et le coach sur ce
plateau box nous avons rencontré marine
tollé la boxeuse de la team farruggia
espère devenir à 30 ans l'une des
figures de ce sport en france
nous lui avons posée à trois questions
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 78 on commence tout de
suite par du football féminin les
joueuses de l'équipe de france se sont
entraînés ce matin à clairefontaine
malgré une météo un peu capricieuse des
jeunes de croissy sur seine ont pu
assister à la séance depuis les tribunes
et encourager leurs protégés pendant
plus d'une heure à montage de jules à
grenoble il
ils ont fait beaucoup de bruit plus de
400 jeunes venus principalement de
croissy sur seine se sont rendus ce
lundi matin à clairefontaine pour un
entraînement de l'équipe de france
féminine a rendez vous programmé quatre
jours seulement avant leur premier match
de coupe du monde
j'aime bien tu as envie de crier allez
les bleus
c'est bien si on les voit pas tous les
jours c'est les professionnels allez les
bleus c'est pas tous les jours qu'on
peut y voir c'est
passer des joueuses professionnelles
c'est ben hassine c'est magnifique ça me
donne envie de devenir peau de dégâts
les villes sélectionnées par la fifa
croissy-sur-seine recevra les bleus
pendant la coupe du monde pour créer
l'effervescence la commune n'a pas
hésité à affréter plusieurs bus pour
emmener les jeunes à la session d'avoir
la joie d'avoir des enfants heureux
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a accueilli
l'équipe de france c'est pour
transmettre ses valeurs de ce sport et
d'amour et de joie comment on trouve ici
dans un stade
après les tribunes direction les
terrains la matinée s'est terminée par
une séance de dédicaces avec les
joueuses tous ont voulu un souvenir de
cette journée de la compétition approche
plus plus agrandi pour iliad
effervescents son club c'est bien pour
nous ce positif
les enfants ils sont pleins d'énergie
donc un emprunt c'est bien ça fait
plaisir
en plus il ya beaucoup d'enfants et
c'est vrai qu'à notre âge en bas on
rêvait quoi de ça une belle surprise ce
matin ses regrets après avoir rencontré
les jeunes de croissy sur seine les
bleus fouleront pour la première fois la
pelouse du stade omnisport de la vie ce
jeudi six joueurs pour un entraînement à
huis clos avant leur premier match
contre la corée du sud
on continue à parler de cet entraînement
de l'équipe de france et des jeunes de
croissy sur seine qui ont pu approcher
leur idole le maire de la commune jean
roger à davin et anne-sophie au massat
la directrice générale des services nous
ont rejoints sur ce plateau bon soir
vous soit alors comment s'est passée
cette journée très bien un peu plus
vieux mais ça on peut pas rien faire
mais très bien vous avez vu le cri des
enfants la joie y'a pas réservé la météo
n'ont malheureusement pouvait pas tout
faire
ce qui nous a vraiment plus et les
enfants heureux et c'était pour nous le
plus important de votre côté comment
vous l'avez trouvé cet entraînement va
magnifique 1 c'est une occasion de
rencontrer enfin d'une rencontre entre
ces jeunes
et c'est cette menace et les membres de
l'équipe de france féminine on a
toujours voulu associer les enfants et
faire partager ces moments à croissy
c'est pour ça qu'on travaille c'est ce
qui nous motive nous en interne c'est
pouvoir organiser ces moments là et ces
rencontres qui sont essentiels dans la
vie de nos jeunes ça n'a pas été trop
dur a organisé une sortie comme celle-là
c'est toujours un petit peu compliqué
surtout quelque chose se sont fait au
dernier moment avec des changements de
programme mais le plaisir des enfants
efface toutes les difficultés qu'on peut
avoir avant on a la chance à pratiquer
d'avoir une équipe mobilisée des
services prêts à travailler toujours
plus pour ce genre d'événement donc on
est accompagné on est soutenu et en
général ça se passe très bien
alors je rappelle que l'entraînement
devait se dérouler à croissy-sur-seine
et qu'il a été déplacée suite à une
dérogation 1 c'est bien ça monsieur
maire dérogation de l'équipe de france
sont petites bisbilles entre la fifa et
l'équipe de france de football qui a
préféré continuer à s'entraîner sur
clairefontaine et donc d'un autre côté
c'était aussi intéressant de pouvoir
amener nos enfants à clairefontaine
comme le lieu magique donc déplacements
en cars partent tôt ce matin dont je
pensais une souvenez dont une journée
dont ils vont se souvenir très
longuement parce que effectivement on va
sur place on rencontre des sportifs de
haut niveau n'a pas l'habitude on est
soi-même sportif qui développe des
valeurs qui sont importantes l'esprit
d'équipé l'exemplarité le courage et
donc c'est vrai était vraiment important
d'aller les voir les jeunes avaient
révisé les chants de supporters dans le
bus ou pas ça dépend des rébus il ya des
bus où ça a été un peu plus mouvementé
que d'autre chose confirmée début c'est
un peu plus bruyant est déjà
enthousiaste des au départ et des bus un
peu plus calme aussi mais avec la même
envie de partager ce moment mais je vous
ont été accessibles en hypnose ont été
accessibles bien sûr les cinq dernières
minutes de l'entraînement
on est descendu les enfants sont
descendus au bord du terrain et il ya eu
un moment des changes
assez long où il ya pu avoir autographes
et chant chelfi petite discussion même
avec les joueuses les enfants en tout
cas son venir à me plonger dans le bus
puisqu'il s'échange et les autographes
un petit peu comme les images panini ils
disaient tiens moi the wendy renard
tonnes à une autre ans et s'enregistrer
dans le bus donc ça a continué une bonne
partie au moins est reparti content oui
alors on a vu beaucoup de filles aussi
dans le reportage
est-ce que c'était important de les
emmener peut-être pour susciter des
vocations
alors il faut savoir qu'à croatie on a
une équipe féminine de football qui
fonctionne pas mal donc c'était aussi
une des raisons pour lesquelles on a
candidaté sur place pour pouvoir
développer ça les filles oui on a lavé
au temps des enfants mais c'est
important oui donc penser que ça peut
susciter des vocations jeu de reportages
en avait une qui semblait intéressé pour
jouer au football
et pourquoi pas devenir professionnel
c'est une joueuse de l'équipe du club de
croatie qui est déjà beaucoup investi on
a même des joueuses des jeunes joueuses
qui sont partis rejoindre déjà le psg
féminin oui l'équipe féminine fin les
filles à croissy si une section qui est
importante se prend de la place et il ya
une vraie envie de partager y compris
dans les écoles ou même dans les cours
de récréation les filles sont associés
aux matchs de foot donc oui des
vocations et encore mieux si ça peut
être la croatie au football de croatie
alors jeudi prochain en fin d'après midi
les joueuses de l'équipe de france ou
foulée justement la pelouse de croissy
sur seine au stade omnisports du chemin
de ronde comment ça va se dérouler ça va
se dérouler que par rapport selon
l'organisation fifa donc le bus va
arriver avec une escorte et des moyens
de sécurité
le site est complètement privatisé pour
l'arrivée de l'équipe de france la
sécurité les agents et les journalistes
pourront accéder au site un petit peu
avant
la sortie des joueuses des vestiaires
jusqu'au terrain un entraînement sur les
pelouse de croatie qui sont prêtes qui
sont belles je me suis même permis une
petite comparaison ce matin à
clairefontaine et je suis
particulièrement fier d'avoir une équipe
en interne notamment nos jardiniers et
carvin du stade qui vont les accueillir
avec une condition pelouse
exceptionnelle a aussi belle que celle
de clairefontaine ce matin on va
peut-être le recruter à clairefontaine
potel dans les prochaines semaines alors
il n'y aura pas que l'équipe de france 1
qui viendra à croissy-sur-seine y aura
également l'afrique du sud les causses
et les états unis
c'est une vraie satisfaction oui c'est
une fois la défaction parce que d'abord
c'est des villes d'europe qui sont
plutôt de langue anglo saxon or nous on
à l'école anglaise surcroît si donc ça
c'était très important c'est le hasard
mais très important et puis en finale
l'équipe des états unis numéro un
mondial championne du monde en titre
championne du monde en titre des icônes
quand vous parlez de vos enfants des
joueuses donc oui on a vraiment la
palette total quatre équipes quatre
équipes sur après on attendra aussi les
huitièmes de finale les quarts de finale
on fera partie des terrains haute pour
ces carrés ces huitièmes on espère que
le tirage au sort favorable à croatie
mais on est sûrs d'avoir une belle
affiche dès les huitièmes et les quarts
à croatie mais il ya eu des gros travaux
engagés par la ville alors les gros
travaux étaient essentiellement fait
pour l'euro 2016 puisqu'on avait été
contre bath de l'équipe de russie
là on a entretenu nos terrains parce
qu'on savait qu'on allait accueillir la
coupe du monde on a investi sur une
tondeuse cette année mais on a surtout
un savoir faire et des gardiens qui
préparent leur terrain depuis deux ans
qui ont été formés également avec les
jardiniers du parc des princes
et les jardiniers de la fifa donc on a
un savoir-faire permanent qui nous
permet de ne pas engager des grosses
dépenses mais d'avoir retenu un peu
constant qui est un peu la politique
générale à croissy sur tous nos
équipements c'est aussi leur lit et des
équipes de nationale d'angleterre
c'est comme une référence qui était venu
ici pour expliquer encore plus comment
fallait faire pour vraiment avoir un
beau gazon et en quoi c'est important
pour une ville d'accueillir des
sélections nationales est ce qu'il y
aura des retombées
alors on n'est pas tellement seul est
retombée on est une petite ville par
rapport à tout autour de nous des
grandes ligues donc des petits moyens
donc il fallait trouver un projet
exceptionnel un petit peu comme la ville
de croatie première priorité vous l'avez
compris toi leur priorité à la jeunesse
c'était plus important ensuite
exemplarité il fallait trouver quelque
chose qu'on puisse avoir tout seul et
continuer à le faire et à partir de la
baisse qui est important c'est que vous
avez un certain nombre de personnes qui
viennent ça nous permet d'avoir de la
notoriété
ça nous permet aussi de s'ouvrir sur le
monde puisque vous avez parlé d' équipes
étrangères
et puis ça nous permet aussi d'avoir
toute une communauté qui se réunit comme
devrait le faire chaque maire avec bien
entendu la ville exceptionnelle mais
aussi la population vous avez des
enfants qui sont là
si vous alliez dans la ville ya aussi
une programmation artistique dont il n'y
a pas que les footeux qui sont ici et
puis une autre chose qui est très
importante c'est un développement des
élus et des agents
les agents dans leur savoir faire les
élus parce que bien entendu pour pouvoir
avoir une coupe du monde accroît s'il a
fallu négocier se battre de manière
assez importante pour avoir un certain
nombre de contacts et pouvoir se faire
sélectionner et vous allez continuer à
cueillir des sélections nationales
oui bien sûr alors on va pas vous en
parler plus longtemps parce qu'on n'est
pas les seuls à le faire mais il ya des
choses qui se profile comme la coupe du
monde de rugby comme les jeux olympiques
est forcément sera candidat vous allez
organiser également une fan zone aussi
pour cette coupe du monde féminine oui
on a une femme zone quand madonna ce qui
sera juste à côté du stade le choix a
été de mettre cette fan zone cette fois
ci au coeur des entreprises et à côté du
stade de manière à avoir une
identification fortin de cet aspect
sport de haut niveau pour la ville et
cette fameuse zone retransmettra les
demi finales le match d'ouverture les
demi finales et finales et la fête de la
musique spéciale états unis merci
beaucoup déplacé sur ce plateau bonne
coupe du monde féminine à
croissy-sur-seine je rappelle que
l'équipe de france jouera son premier
match ce vendredi à 21h face à la corée
du sud au parc des princes on continue
notre page football féminin par un état
des lieux complet et des sections
féminines dans les yvelines
elle représente au total 6 2 % des
licenciés du département un reportage de
marylène heye à pishin au juste les
jeunes filles sont invités à s'essayer
au foot
objectif recruter des joueuses pour
étoffer voir créer de nouvelles équipes
féminines le mani football club et ses
400 licenciés s'est lancé dans le
football féminin cette année 24 joueuses
sont inscrits et ont leurs créneaux
d'entraînements dédié
je pensais pas que c'était bien parce
qu'il y avait des garçons qui jouent et
et qui est défi bassin de nouveau ses
confrères et regarder tout le match à la
télé et du coup ça m'a donné envie de
plus m'intéresser au goût pour les
motiver le club va les amener au parc
des princes assister au match
d'ouverture de la coupe du monde
féminine
le 7 juin prochain dans le district d
evelyne les féminines représente 6,2
pour cent des licenciés alors qu'elles
n'étaient que 3 2% lors de la saison
2013 2014
un effectif en croissance qui correspond
à la volonté de féminisation du football
du président et de son équipe
l'idée est qu'il que certains présidents
ont maintenant c'est de se dire bah il
faut peut-être que j'ai une équipe de
football garçons de - pour pouvoir
laisser de la place à la création d'une
équipe de filles ça il ya dix ans
c'était impensable en tout cas ce
n'était pas le cas
et maintenant l'idée est en train de
faire son chemin c'est que c'est pas
parce que les garçons jouent au foot
depuis toujours qu'il faut pas aussi
laissé un petit peuple assure aux
joueurs seuls 37 clubs sur son 53 dans
les yvelines propose des sections
féminines pour les encourager le
district les aide en leur attribuant du
matériel mais puisque des joueuses dans
les yvelines
on souhaite également plus de formatrice
il se trouve que malheureusement nous
n'avons pas assez de d'éducatrice nous
avons beaucoup d'éducateurs qui se
former mais pas ses d'éducatrice une
formation d'éducatrice c'est gratuit
c'est gratuit
c est payant pour les messieurs pour les
hommes c'est gratuit pour les femmes on
distribue des yvelines parce que est
depuis toujours parce que c'est une
façon d'inciter les filles à se former
autre cheval de bataille
l'encadrement sur les 153 club yvelinois
14 sont présidées par des femmes
le district organise des journées femme
franchissez la barrière pour encourager
les mamans un s'investir dans les clubs
de leurs enfants pour leurs débuts
mercredi prochain il faut tout organiser
pour que ce soit bien fait parmi les
quatorze présidents de clubs dans les
yvelines
mireille la faune et celle qui dirige
plus gros et l'encours et ses 800
licenciés après avoir inscrit ses deux
fils au club la mer s'investit pour
prendre de plus en plus de
responsabilités jusqu'à se retrouver à
la tête en juin dernier
au début c'est un challenge on se dit
est ce qu'on va y arriver est ce qu'on
va être reconnue parce que les femmes
dans le foot c'est pas encore
démocratisée mais c'est passionnant
ces passionnés on est très enrichissant
et on travaille avec des personnes
dévouées qui sont passionnés par le
monde du football et des parents un
trimestre de plus en plus la main à la
pâte
la première section féminine d'elancourt
a été créé il y a dix ans aujourd'hui
elles sont 62 licenciés le club compte
également des formatrices une arbitre
une quasi parité au sein de son conseil
d'administration
il est le prochain à recevoir le label
du foot féminin des mains du président
du district toujours sur le football
féminin le district des yvelines
organisé samedi une journée dédiée aux
féminines une trentaine d' équipes du
département à participer à cette
magnifique manifestation à la fois
festive et sportive trois finales
départementales se sont jouées l'après
midi ambiance avec aurélie rond et
marylène heye à pishin ces jeunes
footballeuses de l'usb y ont cours
viennent de remporter la coupe des
yvelines dans la catégorie u16 depuis
quelques années maintenant le district
du département organisent une journée
football film quand on faisait les
finales garçons ont même tenté finale
filles belles et le public aller vers
les finales garçons et puis il y avait
personne devant les finales filles un
jour on a décidé que les finales filles
se passerait en tant qu'hôtel justement
pour en faire la promotion
et à quelques jours du lancement du
mondial féminin de football
les yvelinoises ont démontré qu'elle
n'avait plus rien à prouver sur le
terrain
voilà ce que parce que il n'ya pas que
les garçons qui peuvent gagner
il ya aussi les filles et on est aussi
coupable que les garçons en plus de
trois finales départementales des
animations étaient proposées toute la
journée au public il ya cinq ans au
département des yvelines comptait neuf
cent soixante douze joueuses
aujourd'hui elles sont 2180 a même dit
mme banon
je pense que les parents on peut
commencer à découvrir le foot féminin et
et mieux
comment dire le comprendre parce
qu'effectivement les filles au foot et
ben c'est pas toujours évident pour les
parents là je pense que ça commence à se
démocratiser donc c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt bien
c'est dans la bonne ambiance en plus y'a
pas football masculin surtout à ce
niveau là c'est c'est beaucoup plus
violent pas dire autre chose
et pour clôturer cette journée l'équipe
féminine senior de trappes l'emporter
sans guzet de sa carrière sur scène on
continue ce magazine par du handball
plaisir c'est fait à plaisir pour sa
dernière journée en nationale 3 les
plaisirs aux a déjà assuré de descendre
l'année prochaine on prenait un jeu
offensif face à stella sport se sont
finalement imposés sur le score de 32 à
26 une victoire qui n'aura aucune
conséquence au classement plaisir
termine 10ème sur 12 équipes il n'aura
manqué qu'un point aux joueurs de victor
garrigues et pour se maintenir
le bihan la saison 6 victoires 4 nuls et
12 défaites rendez vous l'année
prochaine en prénationale toujours
handball mais cette fois ci chez les
féminines dans le championnat de
nationale 2 montigny le bretonneux n'a
pu faire mieux que match nul sur le
terrain de stella sport s'amorce ce
samedi soir score final 28 à 28 un
résultat qui n'a aucune conséquence au
classement lézignan montagne coachée par
denys choulet termine à une décevante
huitième place à 13 points du podium
les onze défaites concédées ont pesé
dans la balance un mot de baseball à
présent en première division les cougars
de montigny le bretonneux jouer ce
week-end la 9e journée du championnat
contre les commerces de metz lésigny
montant remporté la première partie sur
le score de 16 à 0 mais se sont fait
surprendre dans le second match ils ont
perdu 10 à 7
les cougars reste deuxième de la poule b
avec un bilan de 12 victoires pour 6
défaites et ils sont toujours qualifiés
pour les playoffs de fin de saison
leur prochain match est programmé le 16
juin prochain à domicile contre le puc
de paris on continue ce magazine par du
basket l'entente le chesnay-versailles
connu un week end magique
les seniors se sont imposés face à paris
en finale de playoffs de prénationale
sur le score de 92 à 60 vous avez bien
entendu 92 à 60 pour nous parler de
cette victoire nous recevons sur ce
plateau le coach olivier patins ainsi
que les joueurs à bamba say you and
abraham et maxine le pichot bichon
pardon bonsoir
alors votre sentiment après cette finale
olivier a tout d'abord de la fierté
puisque c'est le travail d'une saison et
même depuis que je suis arrivé
au chesnay versailles et puis un
soulagement d'accomplir d'accomplir
cette saison et de ne pas trébucher lors
de la dernière marche pas ce qui est
arrivé jusqu'au final fort c'était déjà
quelque chose et puis bah avec le graal
au bout c'est encore plus beau quand
yoann votre sentiment à vous au final
deux points d'écart oui 32.2 coeur bat
je pense qu'on a on a su mettre le bon
rythme en au bon moment tout en gardant
notre notre combativité notre esprit
d'équipé comme on a su le faire
justement le match d'avant mon club
samedi où ça a été aussi très dur non on
est tombé sur une équipe de maisons qui
étaient déjà qualifiés mais qui voulait
aussi le titre donc qu'ils jouaient eux
juste une chose un titre nous ont joué
deux choses angers le titre plus la
montée
donc je pense que voilà on a su on a su
ainsi mettre tout en place pour pouvoir
gagner ce match et assurer notre montée
tranquille où maxime c est une surprise
ou pas ses 32 points d'écart en finale
oui forcément 32 points d'écart c'est
quand même beaucoup
même les
mais c'est l'aboutissement de deux d'un
projet la cuc concrétisation de deux
beaucoup d'efforts des enfants c'était
une belle saison et on termine sur une
belle note finalement bamba c'était
peut-être le match d'avant la
demi-finale contre meudon qui sait jouer
dont vous les avez gagné 78 à 67
ça s'est joué là dessus finalement je
peux plus que sur la finale oui il
fallait gagner ce match pour assurer la
montée
donc on l'a bien fait on a bien joué
donc été présents partout des deux côtés
défense offensif et donc voilà donc
d'une lendemain on a assuré des titres
olivier est ce que jours ont respecté
les consignes ah oui plutôt bien la
victoire du coach avant tout c'est la
victoire des joueurs d'abord et avant
tout puisqu'une fois que le ballon est
élancé sur le terrain je peux apporter
ma petite touche évidemment mais c'est
eux qui qu'ils doivent accomplir les
choses sur le terrain
non après j'ai un groupe j'ai un groupe
qui vit bien j'ai un groupe avec lequel
je prends du plaisir ils prennent du
plaisir aussi entre eux et ça se ressent
immédiatement sur le terrain donc donc
maintenant très très satisfaits de cette
saison encore une fois yoann cette
montée en n3 était attendu pas du tout
bah oui ça fait un moment que ça depuis
qu'on est arrivé à versailles
le projet c'était de retrouver déjà la
nationale 3 après voire plus si
affinités bien évidemment mais déjà déjà
retrouvé
cette ancienne compétition dont
versailles étaient déjà qualifiés un
petit moment mais voilà cette hausse
était attendue elle voulait depuis
depuis deux ans on travaille pour en
tout cas ont travaillé pour il faudra
recruter l'année prochaine bonne
question où il veut non le groupe
le groupe vit bien le groupe est sain
après forcément c'est un plus de
recruter mais on verra bien c'est cette
fin de saison va déterminer le coach
fera ses choix
vous comptez continuer bamba vous avez
38 ans et sa non 40
merci vous allez continuer oui et j'ai
continué de produire les pour
accompagner voilà olivier ce qu'il
faudra pour coter tout simplement la
saison prochaine bah comme l'a dit
maxime c'est une question qu'ils
assistent à la tête de cette équipe
alors oui je serai à la tête de cette
équipe enfin j'ai encore à voir mes
dirigeants mais mais non ils m'ont
confirmé être très satisfait du travail
accompli et moi je suis très satisfait à
la fois encore une fois du groupe mais
aussi de ce que les dirigeants nous ont
apporté donc donc ça va être grand
plaisir que je continuerai à la tête de
cette équipe la saison prochaine
après concernant le recrutement c'est
c'est difficile parce que on a un groupe
qui vit bien un groupe qui qui a qui
manque pas grand chose au final est donc
plutôt que de parler de recrutement je
pense qu'il va falloir compléter
peut-être l'effectif sur quelques petits
manques qu'on peut éventuellement avoir
mais le premier travail ça va être de
garder d'abord tout le monde et après
voilà et après et après on verra ce qui
nous manquera merci à vous d'être passé
sur ce plateau on suivra avec attention
votre prochaine saison en nationale 3 je
crois que vous vouliez dire quelque
chose
oui à revoir après dix ans de
l'association que je vais organiser un
camp de basket du sénégal cet été
du 15 au 25 juillet et l'association
s'appelle sofia qui voue à présent
marine collet est une boxeuse
prometteuses de la team farruggia il
encourt professionnel depuis 2000
cette sportive espère désormais faire à
décoller sa carrière malgré sa défaite
contre hélène lacombe le 18 mai dernier
pour le titre de champion de france nous
lui avons posée à trois questions
[Musique]
c'est ce que j'ai fait avant de faire du
foot non j'ai commencé très petit la
boxe boxe pieds poings à la clé six ans
après petit j'ai arrêté je suis revenu
en boxe anglaise
à l'âge
9h28
allez maintenant
[Musique]
oh
dès novembre 2017 avec un combat qui a
eu lieu au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ici c'est
avant tout dans la continuité
la boxe que j'aime c'est
employé même
ou jamais
28 ans ont ce niveau on allait pas de
regrets pourquoi pas passer en gros
tu as toutes les chances ne pas avoir de
regrets donc on y va et qu'il advienne
que pourra
pour l'instant j'ai eu
cinq combats avec une majorité de
défaite plus ou moins justifiées mais
une majorité des fêtes
avec quand même quelques victoires
s'échappa jamais très loin donc
et puis on voit l'évolution calais à la
limite ça donne envie à un peu continue
[Musique]
on
le problème c'est qu'on développement de
carrière
en boxe féminine
c'est jamais très facile de se projeter
sur du moyen terme ou du long terme
c'est surtout des opportunités comme ce
qui s'est passé là lors de nos derniers
combats ce qui était un championnat de
france parce qu'on l'a pris au vol une
opportunité qui s'est présentée
c'est plutôt comme ça que j'avançais
haïr
erwin alpes en ski
ce qui est potentiellement à notre
portée
[Musique]
avec 115 médaille olympique 41 titres
c'est le sport le plus médaillé en
france les scream discipline que l'on
peut débuter très jeunes pour en savoir
un peu plus on retrouve mélanie poké sur
ce plateau qui revient avec sa chronique
dédiée au sport pour les plus jeunes
bonsoir mélanie on sent michael a pour
les plus jeunes bien sûr mais j'imagine
que ça intéresse beaucoup avoué le
michael vous avez déjà imité les duels
peut-être pas ceux des jo mais j'imagine
que les quatre mousquetaires ision le
droit et je jouais aux quatre
mousquetaires avec mes voisins je lave
ou alors versé comme tout sport sur
comment jeunes c'est encore mieux à
saint germain en laye ont fait de
l'éveil aux sports c'est destiné aux
enfants à partir de 4 ans avec des
ateliers adaptés bien sûr et du matériel
adapté ce ne sont pas de vraies armes
alors il ya une première phase avec un
échauffement il ya ensuite une phase de
jeu pour maîtriser les déplacements
tu piques de l'escrim c'est ce qu'on
voit à l'image du franchissement
d'obstacles du maniement de matériel
avec des échelles de rythme des cerceaux
dr à franchir
et après ils ont une partie escrime donc
de combat et un petit un tout petit tout
petit partie technique où on va essayer
semaine après semaine d'apprendre les
bases vraiment les fondamentaux de
l'activité
l'objectif va être de développer des
qualités sportives de coordination des
équilibres de découvrir le matériel et
les premières phases de combat par le
jeu dans les scream il ya trois armes
est ce qu'ils apprennent rapidement
ou alors ils apprennent assez vite mais
pas chez les tout-petits puisqu'il
débute avec le fleuret avec cette arme
on cherche à piquer son adversaire sur
une surface défini il découvre aussi le
south ce sont deux armes éducative pas
des pc troll ou encore pour eux et je
vous propose d'écouter ce que les
participants m
les fonds qu ai je un franck des
techniques les marges des scream alors
ils vont aussi découvrir les règles de
courtoisie respecter son adversaire le
saluer avant et après chaque combat
les cours d'escrimé avec la compétition
avec plutôt vers 9 ans et pour les plus
petits ça se passe en petits groupes
entre 10 et 14 ans quatorze enfants
parmi eux on trouvera peut-être la
future gap laura flessel et pourquoi pas
jean françois lamour
merci beaucoup à mélanie pour cette
chronique on vous retrouve bientôt pour
votre chronique junior c'est la fin de
cette émission merci d'avoir suivi très
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]